hello everyone and welcome back to the
tournament of Peace currently being
played in Zagreb Croatia it is round
seven and it is Hans miman versus Evan
sov hunts continuing his Onslaught will
try to take take the tournament by storm
and his opponent in this game is a very
strong Dutch Grandmaster like I
mentioned Ian sov who is not only a top
player he's also a top commentator but
also an incredible coach uh in 2016 he
coached the team of Iran and also worked
very much with Al airu GI and also in
2022 uh he trained the usbekistan team
for the Olympiad where they won first
place uh so incredible stuff by him but
now he has the black pieces against Hans
Neiman most um unpleasant thing to have
to do but that's why they are there so
let's see what happened in this one Hans
has the white pieces and he opens with
E4 and we're going to have something
that is very familiar to I believe most
of you Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and now
Bishop to C4 the Joop piano or the
Italian game Bishop to C5 um this is the
Joo piano and now Pawn to C3 the
so-called Main Line although there are
other moves you could play in this
position Knight to F6 we have D3 and now
D6 we have castles and now Pawn to H6 so
very standard stuff been played many
many times Knight beat to D2 and now
Pawn to A5 stopping Pawn to B4 by white
uh Rook to E1 and now we have castles uh
we often mention that going after df2
Pawn doesn't really do anything white
can defend kick away the Knight and the
Rook might even be better placed in E2
than on E1 in in some lines so here just
castles we have Knight to F1 uh Knight
to E7 and now we have Pawn to D4
striking in the center so again Alin
play before nothing new here e captures
C captures and Bishop back to B6 and
here H we have Pawn to H3 a move been
played only once by Alexander FR in his
game against Daniel dney and he was
played not so long ago in in the F gr gr
Swiss uh we have Pawn to D5 now uh and
pawn to E5 offering the trade of Bishop
for Knight here Knight to E4 and now
Bishop back to D3 and here we have Pawn
to C5 the First new move of the game in
the game that we mentioned Alexander PKA
versus Daniel Dy Knight to F5 was played
but here we have Pawn to C5 by Evan and
it is now as of moved 14 that we have a
completely new game so let's see what
happens here Hans goes Knight to G3 he
offers U uh even to to mess up his Pawn
structure with Knight captures um Pawn
captures and only then going something
like Bishop to F5 but instead even goes
Bishop to F5 right away he doesn't want
to capture uh so Hans does accept the
bishop Knight captures on F5 Knight
captures and now Bishop captures on e4
we have D captures on e4 Rook captures
on e4 and now before going after C
captures on D4 we have Queen to D5 going
after the Rook here so Rook to G4
putting pressure on that black king also
Bishop captures and H6 could be annoying
if the Knight remains on F5 so King to
h8 on pinning here uh and queen to D3
putting pressure on the Knight here and
only now does even capture on D4 with
Knight captures on D4 and here comes a
most unpleasant move by Hans the move
from the thumbnail and that is Knight to
G5 and it looks like okay of course
you're not going to capture the knight
uh if you capture the Knight could be
very unpleasant but um uh that's exactly
what even did uh the the the way to play
this is in fact G6 it's a weird move to
to see point is that now after the
Knight moves uh now you will play Pawn
to H5 attack The Rook after Rook G5 you
will attack The Rook once again and now
you will go after Knight to F6 attack
the black queen here you will see a
trade captures captures okay the bishop
defends The Rook it's not a problem
Queen will move somewhere doesn't really
matter where and now you'll play Queen
to E3 and if you don't want to see
something like uh check followed by
Queen H6 check followed by Queen to G7
Checkmate you have to capture on F6 Rook
will capture on C5 and this is the
position that you get equal material
Bishop versus knight uh you you can play
this however after this Knight to G5
move even decided that it was okay to
capture the Knight he played h captur on
G5 and now we have Bishop captur on G5
threatening the nasty Rook to H4 check
which will result in Queen to H7
Checkmate so H there's only one good way
to treat this you could play Pawn to F5
but it's not really good so Knight to F3
check it's best to give back the piece
and play a slightly worse end game and
this is what Evan does Queen captures on
F3 hunt has to accept this as his Queen
was hanging on D3 Queen captures G
captures and now comes Bishop to d8 uh
if you go Bishop to C7 you go after the
pawn so just F4 nothing really happening
here and if F6 e captures G captures and
now Rook to H4 check King to G8 and now
Bishop to H6 Rook to F7 for example and
F5 H this will be very good for white
but objectively this is even even best
for black even played Bishop to d8 and
now Hans went back Bishop to E3 and now
he asks how are you Defending Your
Queens side pawns and okay we have
Bishop to E7 defending the pawn now King
to H1 with the idea of doubling up on
the G file going um after the G7 pawn
and the bishop will be shifted over to
C3 you can push the pawn later on open
up uh this diagonal so this is something
that even has to consider very much uh
before doing anything else so he goes
Rook F to E8 he will put pressure on
that E5 Pawn uh we have Pawn to F4 and
now Bishop to f8 adding a Defender here
and only now does Hans go Pawn to A4 he
stops Pawn to B5 and now those pawns
disconnected like this are a bit weak
Rook to A6 now Shifting The Rook over to
H6 to put pressure on the H3 pawn and
now Bishop to D2 H starts his maneuver
of going after the G7 pawn pawn to C4
clearing this diagonal so the bishop can
come to B4 to trade the defender Bishop
for the attacker Bishop Bishop to C3 and
now first Rook to H6 because if you go
Bishop to B4 right away it's not very
impressive Rook AG G1 you go after the
G7 pawn and once you trade here let's
say captures captures and G6 then Rook
to B1 so now the Rook no longer is
needed on the G file but how are you
defending um everything on the queen
side for example Rook to E7 you defend
the pawn here Rook to B5 comes and okay
you can try something but it's not going
to be great if you want to stop Rook to
C5 you have to play something like Rook
to C7 uh but then you have uh this one
Rook on the queen side the controlling
both of Black's Rooks on the queen side
and moves like E6 are coming it's not
going to be easy maybe even just H4 H5
you put pressure here play E6 you have
Rook H5 uh very very unpleasant stuff uh
so instead after Bishop to C3 even tried
Rook to H6 first and now we have King to
H2 and okay situation on the clock is
that Hans um has some 10 minutes on the
clock even has 36 minutes but H's
position is just much much better it's
that much better that you can even give
up the H three point you don't have to
defend like Hans did to show you Rook
ag1 you you you give up the pawn here
and after King def attacks The Rook Rook
moves you can capture for example on A5
uh and still it's much better for white
but H says nope I'm not going to give
even any counter Play Just King H2 uh
Bishop to B4 now and hun just says all
right Rook K G1 we already tested this
Pawn to G6 and now Rook to D1 the Rooks
are no longer needed on the G file H but
now you will have to worry about moves
like Rook D5 Rook to D7 and so on so
even does trade uh Bishop captures B
captures but now Hans just goes rooked
to uh sorry first even goes Rook to E7
stops Rook to D7 and now Hans goes Rook
to D5 puts pressure on the A5 Pawn so B6
and now Rook to D4 strongest is actually
Rook to D6 but uh it's also Unstoppable
hunts can play pretty much whatever as
long as he wants because there is
nothing black can do here hunt first
righted Rook to D4 maybe just to check
how even would defend it he defended
with with Rook to C7 and then Hans
played Rook to D6 and he was in this
position un move 37 that even Soo
resigns to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here it looks like there
there could be something that you could
do you're only down one Pawn but no
there's nothing you can do here point is
that uh how do you defend the pawn if
you play something like Rook to B7 F5
comes and there's no way to actually
play this your Rook here would be
hanging so you're going to have to
defend it with the King but then F
captures and G6 F captures and G6 and
now let's say Rook captures on C4 and uh
your your pawns are simply too weak now
you're up two pawns and uh you can do
pretty much whatever Rook will come here
you'll pick up another Pawn so any any
any way you play this you will still win
as I as I like to say even if your uncle
was to play this position he would win
with great
ease uh so yeah Hans wins another game
and this puts Hans believe it or not an
on six and six and a half out of seven
which is absolutely incredible and I
believe he is I he either broke 2700
again or he's very close to Breaking
2700 uh he got so many rating points
this month that if he didn't uh fall
below 2700 before entering the
tournament he would actually uh you know
qualify for for the candidates via
highest rating maybe even maybe not okay
but it will be it would be very close it
would be very close if he didn't fall
below at 2700 before the the month of
November uh but yeah what are you going
to do uh he will have to play
consistently in order to achieve
something like that
uh but still incredible stuff he's
playing at a rating performance of
3,03 this tournament uh which is uh I
mean which for classical chess is just
absolutely remarkable uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it we'll
see what Hans does in the next two games
because I don't think he needs to do
anything he already wins the tournament
unless corov wins his round today and
then two more in a row because Anon
corov is the only one who can catch up
to him but uh let me just check how
corov is is doing maybe corov already
finished yeah okay yeah corov seems to
have won his game okay so if corov wins
um uh the last two games then he could
tie with hunts if hunt
um uh doesn't uh perform this admirably
because he's down two points so Hans has
to lose two and corov has to win two in
order to catch up the Hunts and then I
don't know how the ti race will be
settled but if that happens which I find
very hard to believe believe uh not that
Coro will win corov could very likely
take two games uh but uh uh you know
it's uh ver very hard to say and uh
coro's last two coro's last two
opponents are um sorry let me just check
who his opponents are
for oh so sorry uh they don't have the
pairings yet yeah that's really weird
but I don't think he played HT yeah he
didn't play HT so he will still have to
play HT so it will be very interesting
if Coro will be able to do some damage
maybe even take a win against HT yeah we
we'll be interesting we'll see what
happens uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it absolutely
incredible stuff by Hans we'll see if he
can keep this up I would like to wish a
very happy birthday to Crystal salm and
I would like to thank David gasparian
Karin kawash Muhammad soam and David
Anthony for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos s thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to uh uh cover this wonderful
tournament everything else that happens
in the Chess World and of course always
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions uh thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your
day